avec nous ce soir lisandro coelho au
professeur et titulaire de la chaire de
recherche du canada en logistique
intégrée à l'université laval bonsoir
monsieur coelho bonsoir monsieur fillion
quelle est l'importance du cp du
canadien pacifique sur le plan
économique
vous avez bien dire les cp le numéro
deux de l'industrie au canada c'est cinq
majeur une détiennent presque la moitié
du chemin de fer du commandant mon père
qu'on parle d'à peu près 20 mille
kilomètres de rails extrêmement présent
dans l'ouest où il approvisionne les
ports de vancouver et c'est par là où ça
passe beaucoup des importations et
exportations du canada le canadien
pacifique qui a fait l'acquisition pour
plus de 30 milliards de dollars de kenza
silice arden en 2021 et quand on compare
bien on va le voir dans notre tableau la
valeur en termes de revenus 1 milliard
de dollars américains le canadien
pacifique et sixième en amérique du nord
ce qui est quand même important est-ce
que l'impact économique est surtout
important en agriculture je dirais que
c'est encore plus large que
l'agriculture c'est pour l'alimentation
en général et transporte beaucoup des
semences des aliments pour le bétail
donc les prix de la viande de risque de
s'enflammer si la grève durait plus
longtemps puis sinon comme vous avez
bien dit pour l'agriculture ou la ceni
tragique les transports de des
fertilisants de la potasse pour la
période d'essai monde qui commence
sincèrement et donc c'est
particulièrement important à ce moment
ci que pour la saskatchewan notamment
mais pour les producteurs de
fertilisants de potasse que de se
retrouver dans cette situation ils ne
peuvent plus exporté transporter leurs
leur fertilisants
absolument comment comme on vient de le
dire c'est precinct on est dans la
période des séances où les fertilisants
est absolument nécessaire si c'est un
retard de ça va donc retarder sa va
nourrir toute la chaîne
d'approvisionnement de l'alimentation de
ces quelques semaines et d'ici quelques
mois non seulement au canada mais à
l'échelle mondiale quels sont les autres
produits qui sont principalement
affectées par le conflit de travail du
cp actuellement le plus urgent ce sont
des fertilisants pour l'agriculture
c'est ça dure un peu plus longtemps ça
va être encore les semences les grains
décès quelques semaines dans quelques
mois mais tu es sinon aussi on exporte
beaucoup de charbon via le port de
vancouver donc je dirais un grand les
commodités sont très affectés les
commodités les ressources et l'impact
sur les chaînes d'approvisionnement
qu'est-ce qu'on peut prévoir
ça va avoir un impact majeur parce que
l'effet domino en fait si on commence à
rétablir maintenant avec les
fertilisants savoir et hardy ensuite la
partie des grands et l'alimentation et
on va voir l'impact éventuellement sur
les prix des aliments qu'on consomme oui
exactement et d'autant qu'il ya une
inflation qui vient du conflit la guerre
en ukraine présentement qui s'ajoutent à
une inflation qui déjà bien présent dans
les aliments est-ce qui est ce qu'il est
possible de transférer les produits
qu'on ne peut plus transporter par train
les transférer vers le transport par
camion
je dirais que tout est possible mais pas
tout est souhaitable
on a vu que c'est possible d'en donner
des camions de la côte ouest et jusqu'à
ottawa si on veut
c'est possible de transporter des choses
par camion c'est pas du tout souhaitable
c'est un nombre gigantesque de camions
que cela est nécessaire l'impact est
fondamental c'est énorme mais aussi
l'impact économique que ça va ça va
coûter beaucoup beaucoup plus cher donc
on veut surtout régler la crise avec les
cp que de trouver deux autres native
avec les camions parce que le canada
quand même à des chaînes
d'approvisionnement
est ce qu'on pourrait dire qu'elles sont
fragiles
il ya un impact on dirait au moindre
soubresaut
c'est plus juste au canada c'est les
chaînes d'approvisionnement et enrichir
le mondial se sont construites de façon
à ce que elles sont dépendantes de nos
transports fonctionnelle d'une usine qui
est fonctionnel regardez toutes les
stratégies du juste atteint de garder 0
istock sang a très bien servi ça nous a
aidés regarder les chaînes
d'approvisionnement efficace performant
à diminuer les coûts mais une fois où
une usine en chine ou en asie tombe en
panne on a des étagères vides et si chez
nous une fois où il ya une crise de
transport avec une grève dans en porc ou
un chemin de fer qui est bloquée ou une
grève comme celle qu'on voit maintenant
les chaînes d'approvisionnement elles
dépendent d'un transport fonctionnel
c'est un transport les pertes nettes
n'est pas fonctionnel les faits on sait
qu'on s'en soit immédiatement quels sont
les principaux trajet emprunté par le
canadien pacifique ils sont présents ici
au québec qui sont présents aux portes
de nos fondements et à l'usom centre de
transbordement dans la ville de québec
mais ils sont très très active dans l
ouest du pays à partir du manitoba puis
comme je dis avaient-ils il
approvisionne beaucoup les ports de
vancouver avec l'achat de caen sa série
un plan rhône un très bon une guérison
très forte vers les etats unis aussi et
vert vers le mexique même monsieur
coelho merci d'avoir été avec nous
c'était très intéressant et très
éclairant merci à vous
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit